dramatic new video appears to show actor  George Clooney's crash in Italy  surveillance footage obtained by an  Italian newspaper shows a blue vehicle  veer into oncoming traffic yesterday one  scooter barely avoids the car before the  scooter clooney was reportedly riding  slams into it Clooney was thrown about  10 feet into the air and then hit the  ground the driver and other witnesses  checked on his condition Clooney was  travelling to the set of a TV series  he's shooting on the island of Sardinia  he was briefly hospitalized  a spokesperson for Clooney told The  Associated Press the actor is recovering  at home and will be fine  George if you're listening they are glad  you are well but please no more scooters  no more motorcycles Wow I mean you  really see that's dangerous it's not  lucky to be alive i key to be ok we are  glad he is a minute you're on your way  to work next minute something like that  happens